for yuliya fedesyuk time stands still
she spoke to her husband arseniy as he
was about to surrender to russian forces
after he was ordered to abandon the last
post in mariopol
the famed azov regiment had held the
city for months in a steel plant in one
of the war's most dramatic standoffs
arsenic my husband
when
other regiment was surrounded
actually he called me and and he told me
that everything is okay but it was not
at that time because they were
under the attack of huge bombs
he called again briefly twice from
olinevka prison in eastern ukraine
then last friday the prison erupted in
flames killing more than 50 soldiers
russia said it was a ukrainian missile
strike ukraine said russia blew up the
prison to hide the torture of ukraine's
most legendary fighting force
do you know he's alive
definitely no because
i can only tell that he is not in the
list of dead soldiers which was posted
by russians but that list is not
verified by by ukrainian government so
i don't know i'm wondering actually
[Music]
on thursday in kiev the families of the
azov regiment called for their release
[Music]
the sign says mario paul the last stand
of the azov regiment and yulia is here
together with the other families asking
for them to come home
[Applause]
russia has declared the azov regiment a
terrorist organization
russia has used the regiment's early
association with far-right groups and
the use of allegedly nazi-related
symbols is justification for what it
calls the denotification of ukraine
current and former azov fighters reject
that assertion
russia made us of part of their
mythology part of their propaganda
without this myth about nazis from azov
the russian propaganda about
denacification as a reason for so-called
military operation falls apart
for the families of azov the battle is
now theirs to carry on
they were fighting for us in mariopol
they were fighting for us during
this
eight years they were defending us and
now we have to do the same thing now we
have to defend them and we have to save
them
until her husband returns for yulia
fetisouk the battle of mariopol never
ends
john hendren al jazeera keefe